when you have people coming over and
there they are excited to taste what
you're making and you kind of want to
show off you know it's very easy to do
things like to throw roast in the oven
that's always my kind of standby because
that way I don't actually really have to
cook but you can make a roast chicken
with 40 cloves of garlic or roast
chicken with tons of lemon and herbs put
in the cavity it to infuse the chicken
and you throw in some baked potatoes and
some carrots and leeks and you've got a
beautiful dinner so I think roasts are
probably the easiest thing for people to
serve when that people come over it's
just it's so no muss no fuss and you can
you know kind of relax and then make the
rest of the entrees the side dishes and
the desserts so that's what I always
recommend we do on epicurious have a ton
of things for people to entertain with
and Nigella Lawson in particular does a
very nice job of entertaining recipes I
use a lot of chef recipes while I
entertain because I know that they're
kind of simple in some ways but they've
got a little kind of exotic kick to them
so that's always a little fun I think
when you're entertaining you want to
give people both comfort and surprise at
the same time so you might want to make
something very comforting like macaroni
and cheese but you add truffles to it so
it's very luxurious